oh tick tock everyone's least favorite
website that everyone loves to hate
let's watch
seals reminds me of my dog so much i
love it
i feel like they shouldn't be alive
they're too fat how do you get so fat
they eat a lot of fish i don't know oh
more water content let's go
no no
stop no
that is not real crimes isn't real
privacy isn't real i refuse to believe
it
why have i never seen a crab swim before
what
oh he's missing a claw
crimes are coming to kill us i know it
this reminds me of another tick tock
here's how crimes are made
cry barmy's coming to take over the
world
[Music]
we stood no chance the crab worse begins
you know people say they hate tick tock
and i don't get it but then i watch tech
talks like these and i'm like all right
i get it
at the premature air in slog and right
beside me
is slug police station i never went
there for this
i think i got like two words for that
sentence okay i get it
all right tick-tock haters back off i
get it so me and my boys flew to china
for a holiday
when we checked into our hotel we
realized the receptionist
was asleep so we woke her up
oh damn
[Music]
excuse me hey get up get up right now
get up right now get up get up
who says that get up get up right now
you just seem like you're robbing her or
something
get up you need to wake up right now get
up right now what a dick move
completely harmless like you can touch
them touch one
they start bouncing and moving around is
that what is that
just every time yeah ew
oh it's spiders and they can't
they do and can crawl on you so you can
take a bunch
right here no and they will no
and just all over and it's really not
that big of a deal
it's a big deal you cannot say it's not
a big deal when it's a big that's a big
deal you're done
cancel this man man that kind of gave me
like studio ghibli vibes the coal
workers
what the [ __ ] i gotta sorry i gotta see
look edgar
it's you it's you
oh god look at his little tongue
oh you're so cute
[Music]
okay here's big fart oh [ __ ]
oh
hey alexa i want
you look like you enjoy it i don't like
this stop it just an
otter having to i just say this so i
could show marzia
and she said that otters do that it's
normal
it's so cute why aren't you cute like
that
huh i useless
hey guys look how cute this dog is
huh you're scared of water beggar sees a
puddle
he makes sure to go as far away from the
puddle as possible because
water will kill you right edgar
yeah i just walked by your friends and i
need to tell you that the weekend you're
away
is not the only time that they could do
their birthday party
oh choosing to do it the weekend you're
away and
you know tick tock help me find marissa
i bet it was her friend clara
need to clean your oh tongue came out
more
oh
no
oh my god edgar
the lord has come back to bless the
lambs
we have a thousand year harvest
it's me all right i gotta watch space
jam two now it had to be
shoguza so
apparently i'm on cat tick tock which
should make you very nervous edgar
look how dumb the cats are they're funny
at least they don't just scratch their
ears all day
[Music]
[Laughter]
look you're not looking oh my god
so annoying i cannot tell if this is
real or not
yep all right so you guys must be loyal
to each other right well of course
all right so for today's video can i
have you guys take each other and check
each other's messages and you know check
out the apps and you know messages and
all that stuff is that okay with you
guys
yep so they do a loyalty chat where's
your phone
all right yeah checking phone too i
thought we were just doing one person
switching around oh no
i checked both phones real quick just
real quick
she knew his password real quick huh
[Applause]
what do you mean it's called trust
because you
you have it so you can show it
why you have to give me your phone
so i can show them
this [ __ ] how about we not why not
wait is there something that should be
on your phone that's on your phone he
goes through my phone all the time
oh so it shouldn't be a problem then
great fantastic all the time
well what's the problem though
and go through phones you're done
do not it's just it's just like
i didn't think i was going to be in this
i thought i didn't think anything into
me i thought i was only testing it i
don't want to do it there
leave this leave this thought leave her
this is crazy dude i'm never going on a
carnival ride ever again
ever ever ever ever look at that
damn i'd be so no
dude props to the people for helping out
like damn i'd be kind of scared i mean i
would do it
music honestly i wouldn't even need all
these people around i could just hold it
down myself really but
yeah so i showed this to marzia
and she was like oh yeah that's uh
that's an italian one
you said it just like that i'm like no
i'm sure they have these everywhere okay
and they're mass produce whatever then i
click on a profile
italy trip trips to italy
this could be me and marzia dying on the
carnival right
here comes the boy
hello boy
here comes the boy
[Music]
hello boy
i can tell you and your cat have a deep
deep personal relationship
built on trust friendship and love and
kindness and gentleness
just like you and me edgar right huh
look you wake up the same way
practically why do you look so pathetic
you're like the least threatening dog
ever have you seen once upon a time in
hollywood
can you be a little bit like that dog
please if marilyn manson or
whatever his name is come and attack me
i need you to defend hey
here here hold this
does he look threatening okay
you gotta look them in the eye look them
in the air you gotta threaten them
there you go kill them
not my owner okay face me
can i sleep
you're doing great you're doing great
again you're doing great
you're killing it all right okay i want
to i want to see your opinion on this
video
[Applause]
you're doing so good oh look he's upset
wasn't that upsetting
i would never do i would hold the board
for you edgar
what an idiot all you have to do was
hold the board
[Applause]
and why why didn't the woman filming not
just drop the [ __ ] phone and help him
i would save you a million times do you
hear me
sorry i need to stop doing that i'll get
cancelled it's a fake back
it's funny for no reason
all right you can go back
[Music]
these are quite popular
[Music]
bro it's too high okay ready
it's kind of sweet kind of wholesome
she's not even mad about it
if that was two dudes it would be a
different story
when you wanna quit amazon but remember
who you're working for
[Music]
ah see it's the same for me and you and
yeah
except i hate you i'm just kidding
it's literally my hair
why did we keep doing that
watch that with audio only
[Music]
damn
i've been so pissed the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
why you say watch out for that i said
that's some chad [ __ ] i agree great meme
i love when random old people
go viral and tick-tock it's just
phenomenal it's like a hidden treasure
that the algorithm has picked up
you know this is going to be us when
we're [ __ ] 80
and schmick smock is trending like how
do i use this filter i don't get it
man was just trying to check out the
anime filter
all right let's end it with the greatest
clip i probably have ever seen
so i had this haunted hand haunted
mansion or something
[Music]
so the memes
[Music]
i love it so much it's so good and that
kids
is how i met your mother i love how you
just goes with it
it just goes along they're still running
forever
across the hills across the seams
oh yeah
all right that's enough tech talk hope
you guys enjoyed if you did like
subscribe support and i'll see you bro
tomorrow thanks for watching
you thought it was game but true
relevance
never really died welcome to the first
undead game use any item in your
inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator add some of
our patented stickers in there
stickers our emotions memes our emotions
express your emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
full circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this